all right chris thank you for that well
high rent prices forcing hundreds of
residents to rally today hoping to find
a solution renters have collected
thousands of signatures to push a ballot
initiative that would prevent rent
increase in north las vegas
sometimes it's hard to tell him
just wait until i get the next check if
i have extra buy it gladys blanco says
talking about finances with your
children is a tough conversation she
recently began cutting corners on her
budget i live in a house i pay right now
paid like a thousand dollars they raised
like 400 it's hard because i have to
like
when i buy food i have to watch what i'm
gonna buy
blanco joined the culinary union and
hundreds of other struggling renters on
thursday in north las vegas looking to
put rent control initiative on the
upcoming election ballot short-term
mental corporations massive investments
and then they corner the market and
they're jacking up the rent because they
can solution is we've got to stop them
with neighborhood stability the
ordinance would prevent a landlord from
increasing rent for the rental unit
during the first year after that a
90-day written notice would be needed
for the hike governor steve siselek says
nevada needs rent control if i'm right
and the people do support it we're going
to be addressing this during the session
in terms of how to move it forward in a
statement the nevada state apartment
association says any initiative to cap
rents has never provided sound and
effective solutions and the culinary
union's refusal to meet with the rental
housing industry will negatively impact
north las vegas its residents and its
economic diversification efforts
as a box of signatures were carried into
city hall and the issue handed over to
voters blanco hopes her community will
protect each other we really need it
well in a statement the city of north
las vegas said we welcome that our
community partners are working to find a
solution to the statewide affordable
housing crisis all local jurisdictions
in southern nevada have been struggling
with affordable housing and we look
forward to working with the culinary
union to solve this spiraling crisis
impacting our working families